[Music]
[Andrew Ng] Today people are entering AI from all
walks of life and sometimes people still
wonder is AI a right path for me.
[Fei-Fei Li] The truth is, if I could enter
AI back then more than 20 years ago,
today anybody can enter AI because AI
has become such a prevalent and
globally impactful technology.
[Andrew Ng] You actually started out not studying
computer science or AI but you started
out studying physics and so how did you
make that switch from physics to AI?
[Fei-Fei Li] Physics was my passion all the way through you
know middle school, high school, college, and one
thing physics has taught me till today is really
the passion for asking big questions, the
passion for seeking North Stars. And one thing I
did was reading up stories and writings of
great physicists of the 20th century. It was really
interesting to notice that many of the writings
towards the later half of the career of these
great physicists were not about just the physical
world, but ponderings about equally audacious
questions like life, like intelligence, like human
conditions. That really got me very curious about
the topic of intelligence. One thing led to another,
during college time I did intern at a couple of
labs, especially vision related, and I was like wow,
this is just as audacious a question to ask as the
beginning of the universe or what is matter made
of. And that got me to switch from undergraduate
degree in physics to graduate degree in AI. So I
think it is very exciting to be entering the science
of intelligence and and studying AI today. [Music]